en ciudades como er pin pegada a kiev y
bombardeada por rusia sólo hay una forma
de ir pasando por este tablón de madera
medio hundido en el agua en un río que
divide la ciudad más de 10.000 personas
lo han cruzado en los últimos días a
muchas heridas
nos estaban esperando nos movimos en una
sola fila que destruyeron cuando
empezaron a caer proyectiles de morteros
inmediatamente me volaron la pierna a
medida que los refugiados avanzan muchos
deciden abandonar sus pertenencias para
agilizar el trayecto conservando sólo lo
más importante para ellos en medio del
caos sanitarios de primera línea
atienden a los heridos y civiles
voluntarios intentan ayudar con el
transporte de ciudadanos
omb las horas ayer murieron varias
personas incluidos niños y estamos
sacando a gente nos acercamos debajo del
puente agua como rápidamente a la gente
la sacamos a no vive lynch un lugar
seguro hacemos lo que podemos hacer
muchas
fuentes oficiales estiman que las
evacuaciones en este barrio dormitorio
de kiev continuarán todas durante tres o
cuatro días aunque algunos todavía se
niegan a irse y otros lo han hecho en
contra de su voluntad
francamente no me quiero ir para siempre
porque ucrania es mi país pero tengo
hijos y quiero salvarlos en el caso de
que las tropas lleguen a kiev pero
espero que no lo hagan primero para
salvar a mis hijos aterrizaré y luego
volveré
a pesar de las promesas de seis
corredores humanitarios de moscú y las
negociaciones de paz en belarús con las
tropas rusas cercando las inmediaciones
de la capital kiev muchos temen su caída
algo que supondría una derrota moral y
táctica para ucrania